welcome back everyone this is part four
in our series on contextual word
representations we are going to be
talking about a robustly optimized bert
approach aka roberta
so recall that i finished the burnt
screencast by listing out some known
limitations of the burp model most of
which were identified by the original
bert authors themselves
and top of the list was simply that
although the original burp paper does a
good job of exploring ablations of their
system and different optimization
choices there's a very large landscape
of ideas here and most of it was left
unexplored in the original paper
essentially what the roberta team did is
explore more widely in this space that
is the robustly optimized part of
roberta
so what i've done for this slide here is
list out what i take to be the central
differences between bert and roberta and
i'll follow this up with some evidence
from the roberta paper in a second
first let's go through the central
differences beginning with this question
of static versus dynamic masking
so for the original burp paper what they
did is create four copies of their data
set
each with different masking and then
those four copies were used repeatedly
through epochs of training
the roberta team had the intuition that
it would be useful to inject some
diversity into this training process so
they went to the other extreme dynamic
masking every single example when it's
presented to the model is masked in a
potentially different way via some
random function
there are also differences in how
examples are presented to the model so
presented two concatenated document
segments this was crucial to its next
sentence prediction task whereas for
roberta we're just going to have
sentence sequences that is pairs that
may even span document boundaries
relatedly whereas bert had as one of its
central pieces this next sentence
prediction task
roberta simply drops that as part of the
objective here that simplifies the
presentation of examples and also
simplifies the modeling objective now
roberta is simply using a mass language
modeling objective
the uh there are also changes to the
size of the training batches so for bert
the batch size was 256 examples roberta
cranked that all the way up to 2 000.
there are differences when it comes to
tokenization so as we've seen bert use
this very interesting word piece
tokenization approach which mixes some
sub word pieces with some whole words
roberta simplified that down to just
character level byte pairing coding
which i think leads to many more word
pieces
intuitively
there are also differences in how the
data the model was trained so bert
trained on a substantial corpus the
books corpus plus english wikipedia is a
lot of data indeed roberta again cranked
that up even further they trained on the
books corpus the cc news corpus the open
webtex corpus and the stories corpus a
substantial increase in the amount of
trading data
there are also differences in the number
of training steps and there's a subtlety
here so for the burnt model it was
originally trained on 1 million steps
the roberta model was trained on 500 000
steps which sounds like fewer steps but
overall this is substantially more
training in virtue of the fact that the
training
batch sizes are so much larger for
roberta than they are for bert
and finally the original bert authors
had an intuition that would be useful in
getting the optimization process going
to train just on short sequences first
the roberta team dropped that idea and
they train on full length sequences
throughout the life cycle of
optimization
there are some additional differences
related to the optimizer and the data
presentation i'm going to set those
aside if you want the details i refer to
section 3.1 of the roberta paper
so let's look at a little bit of
evidence for these various choices
starting with that question of dynamic
versus static masking
so this is the primary evidence they're
using three benchmarks squad mnli and
sst2 and you can see that more or less
across the board dynamic masking is
better not by a lot but dynamic masking
also has going for this intuition that
you know bird is kind of data
inefficient we can only mask out a small
number of tokens and it feels like it
ought to be useful to inject a lot of
diversity into that so that a lot of
different tokens get masked as we go
through the training process but the
choice is of course supported
numerically here i think pretty
substantially
this side slide this table here
summarizes the choice about how to
present examples to the model and this
is also a little bit subtle so
numerically the doc sentences approach
was best and this was an approach where
they just two they took contiguous
sentences from within documents but
treated a document boundary as a kind of
hard boundary that's numerically better
according to the benchmark results but
they actually decided to go with the
full sentences approach and the reason
for that is in not respecting document
boundaries it is easier to create lots
of batches of exactly the same size
which leads to all sorts of gains when
you think about optimizing a large model
like this so basically they decided that
those gains offset the slightly lower
performance of full sentences as
compared to doc sentences and that's why
this became their central approach
here's the the summary of evidence for
choosing 2k as the batch size you can
see that they chose 256 which was the
bert original 2k and 8k
and 2k looks like the sweet spot
according to mli sst2 and this kind of
pseudo perplexity value that you get out
of bi-directional models like bert and
roberta
so that's a clear argument and then
finally when we come to the just the
amount of training that we do uh the
lesson here apparently is more is better
on the top of this table here we have
some comparisons within the roberta
model pointing to 500k is the best and i
would just remind you that that is
overall substantially more training than
was done in one million steps with bert
in virtue of the fact that our batch
sizes for roberta are so much larger
in closing i just want to say that
roberta too only explored a small part
of the potential design choices that we
could make in this large landscape
if you would like to hear even more
about what we know and what we think we
know about models like burt and roberta
i highly recommend this paper called the
primer by virtology which has lots of
additional wisdom and insights and ideas
about these models